building 116 San julianska Street in
Central Key was struck at around 8 21 in
the morning
half of it was reduced to a pile of
rubble
Nadia her husband and two cats lived on
the ground floor they were woken by an
earlier explosion then heard a sound
similar to a roar of motorbike and yet
another explosion no we didn't hear any
sound before
the explosion exactly in our house
so the explosion in the house across the
street you hear this
but here that there was only the
explosion sound
uh so our cats hide in the bathroom
under the bus
we was just we were just shocked
and we were sitting and waiting what's
happening but I told my husband to close
the guest system
and at the same time he looked at the
window and said that this building is
okay so that means they hit us our
building
multiple so-called kamikaz drones had
been launched against Kiev and other
cities
it's called these drones mopeds because
of
because of they do cause panic and
anxiety because you don't know where
they're gonna hit now these drones are
increasingly used in attacks beyond the
front lines the pattern is to launch
them in swarms towards several cities at
the same time in a bit to overwhelm the
air defense systems
building 116 was struck by one of
several that weren't intercepted
Jager gorby is flat share the wall with
the building he stood on the balcony and
saw what he describes as a miniature jet
hovering overhead
small planes that change their speed and
direction he says a nearby power station
could have been an intended target if
you speak about critical infrastructure
but this energy station that not far
from my house is not effective more than
10 years during the last 10 years our
Governors have a plan
to restruct it because it's um it's
Soviet construction it's uh not
effective and it's useful also for small
districts around it's unnormal for
modern uh infrastructure that's why it's
not the critical infrastructure
Dennis's grandmother lived on the third
floor she couldn't escape the impact
her body was discovered under the rubble
three of her neighbors also lost their
lives
The increased use of drones could
indicate that Russia is depleting its
stock of cruise missiles or that Western
sanctions are working
but they have also been effective in
destroying energy infrastructure
plunging parts of Ukraine in darkness as
the cold season is fast approaching